Báo xù chính có tên cú tế là ra ra ra măng giảm cấp nhàng trong quá trình xí chuyển về phía nước ta.
Dù vậy, máu vẫn sẽ về ra gió mạnh và một lượt mưa lẫn trên gióng cho các tình thành phía bắt.
Cái em theo người cơ cao về ngập uống lu quét và xà lữa đất.
Dự báo, chứ trường mai tâm báo sẽ đi vào khu vực khoảng ninh với cơ nổ cấp tâm cấp chính.
Từ đẹp này các nặt phu vài lòng vi vấn đôn cú tô các hai và đau hần rấu gió mạnh dần lên các mấy cơ tâm.
Vùng gần tâm báo cấp chính cấp mời, giật các mấy hai xó miền cao từ hai đến buồn mệt.
Đông bắt bố gió mạnh dần lên bánh biển khoảng ninh.
Gió mạnh nhất sẽ đặt cấp tâm cấp chính giật cấp mời các mấy một.
Từ đẹp này, thử tư đến hết đến từ sau, bắt bố thành hóa nghe ăn sẽ có mời lẫn trên giống.
Các xong ngọt, để phòng lu cao từ bà đồng hai đến bước bảo độc ba.
Muy cơ sẽ giang gặp uống luật khi vùng chung thấp, sật lời đất, lu quét ở buồn gũi.